I don't give a what anyone says on
college I think if you're in college you
shouldn't actually have an opinion about
anything you know I think that you
should probably even if you had a tough
childhood I think you should probably
that spend a decade in the workforce I
do you know it I think or if not in the
workforce used to just spend a decade
hating yourself and becoming fatter and
uglier and Balder and just you know I
mean you should and and then someone you
love should leave you but that said you
know my biggest problem is not what
happens in college campuses because I
don't I try to stay away from college as
much as possible is is really just you
know what what happens to language in
people's free use of language I think
that um I think that you know speech
should be harmful and defang speech is
not speech I think speech should always
have the power to wound and I think it
should be allowed to wound because not
only is that the right pressure valve
that brings you away from actual
physical violence you know but more
importantly it is a it's a preparation
for true pain and life in the sense of
you know when you are spoken to in a
certain way that's harmful but when you
read a book with content that you
consider harmful right um you can't talk
back to it you can ignore it you can you
know tell other people not to read it
right but the idea of translating our
standards for interpersonal speech to a
standard for literature or even just
written communication
that has stood some test of time is
perverse to me the whole point of the
Greeks is that you never know what your
trigger warning is because it's your how
much it's your fatal flaw if someone
told you what your trigger warning was
you probably wouldn't end up you know
killing your father and sleeping with
your mother you know I mean implied in
the history of literature Western
literature is essentially people who
were confronted with people who were not
warned or people who did not heed
warnings right and these things are
supposed to be lessons for us not to set
up our own warnings but they're actually
just supposed to be examples of what
life will do to all of us and maybe
consolations for how to abide